Speaker 1: Let's talk about today's mass shooting.
I guess it's actually yesterday's, but what a
country that when we say the mass shooting, I have
to speculate. Not the one from last Tuesday and
not the one from the previous weekend. I'm talking
about the one from yesterday. Another horrifying
event. Four people have been killed in a mass
shooting at a Tulsa, Oklahoma. It's sometimes
being discussed, this described as a hospital,
maybe more accurately, a medical building.
The gunman is also dead. CBS News has a report
that contains much of the information. We now know
four people were killed in a shooting last night,
Wednesday evening in a medical building on a
hospital campus in Tulsa, Oklahoma. The gunman
is also dead, apparently from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound. Tulsa Police Department Captain
Richard Muhlenberg told CNN multiple people
were wounded. He said it was fewer than ten. No
one had wounds considered life threatening. So
four dead. The shooter dead. An additional up
to ten people wounded with non-life threatening
injuries. He told the Associated Press that the
medical complex was a, quote, catastrophic scene.
The identities of the victims and the gunman
haven't been released as of this moment. By the
time this story publishes, maybe some of that will
have been released. The motive wasn't immediately
known. The shooting occurred a little before
five on the campus of Saint Francis Hospital.
Officers were there within 3 minutes, made
contact with the gunman within another 5 minutes.
The police chief says, I was very happy with
what we know so far regarding the response of our
officers. Certainly an allusion to the response at
the Texas shooting, for sure. Officers encountered
encountered the suspect on the second floor of the
hospital's Natalie building. The gunman is a black
male believed to be between 35 and 40. Armed with
a long gun and a handgun, both weapons appeared
to have been fired. The officers that did arrive
were hearing shots in the building and that's what
directed them to the second floor. So, listen,
this is this is another one of these things where
the details are catastrophic. The death toll is
tragic. It's just it's yet another shooting. But
as always, I find it important to remind you
that there have now been 20 mass shootings
since last week's shooting in Texas. This
is sort of like the next mass shooting that
made the news in a national way. But if
you look at gun violence, archive.org,
and you go back to the day of the Texas shooting,
where, of course, 22 were killed and 17 injured,
there was a shooting in Philly, in Stanwood,
Michigan, in Anniston, Alabama, Memphis,
Tennessee, Colorado Springs, one in Florida, one
in California, another one in Tennessee, Chicago,
Henderson, Nevada, on and on and on. There have
been 20 of these. There was a shooting just two
days ago in Charleston, South Carolina, where
thankfully no one was killed, but ten individuals
were injured. Waco, Texas, had a shooting with
four people injured on Tuesday. And then we get
to this shooting yesterday in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
with five killed. That includes the shooter. The
number injured has not yet been updated on gun
violence, archive.org. So it is not you know, it
would be bad enough if we had the Buffalo shooting
and the Texas shooting and the Tulsa shooting. But
in between that, we've had dozens more shootings
and it just doesn't stop now. After the break,
I'm going to be speaking with Democratic
Congressman Jamie Raskin. Many of you have said,
David, you should really talk to Jamie Raskin.
He's a true progressive and he really cares. And
if anybody's going to get things done in this
Congress, it's going to be Jamie Raskin. Well,
I'm going to speak to him after the break. And
one of the questions I have for him, because we've
been hearing anecdotally this time it's different.
This time it's going to be a different thing. It's
not going to be the same again. I'm going to ask
Jamie Raskin, is there actually any willingness
from Republicans to do something about gun safety
regulations this time, or is it going to be that
same vicious cycle of thoughts and prayers? And
no, we can't touch guns that we've seen so many
times before. That's after the break. Make sure
to find us on Instagram at David Pakman show.